Dolly Parton may be hanging up her coat
of many colors as the country icon
revealed her touring Days Are Over Say
It Ain't So in a new interview with
Pulsar magazine the queen of country
expressed that she has no intention of
going on a full-blown tour anymore
adding I've done that my whole life and
it takes so much time and energy but
Dolly has a very good reason behind her
decision explaining she wants to spend
more time at home with her husband of 56
years Carl Dean she shares we're getting
older now and I don't want to be gone
for four or five weeks at a time
something could happen I would not feel
right about that if I were gone and
somebody needed me or I would feel bad
if I had to leave a tour if somebody got
sick at home and needed me and then I
had to walk out on the fans at 76 years
young Dollar's career has spent 56 years
with some of her biggest accolades
including 11 Grammy Awards and 3 billion
streams worldwide but don't expect Dolly
to disappear from the spotlight anytime
soon as she promises I do know I'll do
special shows here and there now and
then maybe do a long weekend of shows or
just a few shows at a festival the dolly
is also taking advantage of social media
to stay connected with fans saying I
don't ever feel separated from my fans
because in this high-tech world you can
be right with them she is so right I do
love
that she said her reasoning for not
going on tour is not because she's tired
of it or not because she doesn't want to
do it anymore she's like what if I'm
gone if something happens yeah and I
want to be there to help you I know
right I love that and also thinking if
she is on tour then would have to leave
her fans how heartbroken or fans would
be of course they'd understand if
somebody was sick at home but still
that's just a lot of disappointment so I
just love that she's thinking of her
family of her fans she could stop doing
shows all together she wanted to she
could she she could but she's not she's
still going to be doing some weekend
stuff in other shows so I just love that
about her here's the thing that I think
about Dolly Parton and Dolly Parton like
she could do a tour where she goes to
all these cities across North America or
across the world yeah but I think the
people that are real Die Hard dollar
apartment fans will come to her wherever
she is I agree I completely agree yeah
she's special I mean we should go we'll
go I would love to go